こんにちははじめ社長です皆さんアイスクリーム何好きですか世の中にはいろんな医師
求人があるんですけどもその頂点に君臨すると言ったらもちろんこちらハーゲンダッツ
アイスクリームみんな好きだよな
もういさのレベルが違うんですよ
めっちゃ構成だもったいない今の1滴でもったいないから人は口径ナイフクリームなん
ですよも300円くらいする
アーマー絵本と音は本当にもうハーゲンダッツの場になってたらそこの辺のバニラの熱
クリームが比べ物にならないくらい美味しいなおいしく
はぁ
ハァハァばジェリーだよ一緒と言わないんですけれども
なんかこう値段とパッケージそれでなんかこう規制がかかっちゃんぜんじゃねぇかな
っていう説がありましてちょっとそれほどは検証してみようと思います何気ない
ターゲットにハーゲンダッツなんだけども中身が普通のバニラアイスの列を渡します
多分バレませんやすい102人からないそこでパクパクはぎんだってだと思って食って
ない
美味しい光景アートか言うと思うんでその様を今回楽しもうと思います食べバレないと
思いますつーわけで早速上げんだったら中身を書いていきましょうよ
同じくらいうまいん
同じやー完全一緒でしょいるだけじゃなくて味も味も完全に一緒でしょ
半減だったのがおいしいと思ってるんですけどハイカラ
幻想だスーパーカップが一番の風が近かったのでだからハーゲンダッツのもの全部食っ
て開いたこのカップにバカップルだけど移して1回冷凍してか止めます
運動ございます
いつも前の3万円マイクっ
[音楽]
堂々があります強いっぽいよねそうよね比べています
んじゃねぇこれはいいたしました
[音楽]
ん
親がすごいやはい
麻生とかけたよねっとアイパッチスタンドぞそれ舞う配したかッ
ています
勝った本当の豆です
ちょっとぉ取るどれじゃないと溶けているというタレを入れました
やっぱりあえてたらハーゲンダッツにかければなんてこんなん
うん
マック c 組になっているすー
ちょっとと化した分もい不明な
なんだこれなんでこの前のかなっ
ん
ルーマニアと比べて青いするよろしくね全然っていうの
プレビュー前
えっ
ランキングなんか以前使った妹
安永だと感じだしたことを言うと逆に励んだと人もいうと母乳ますました
見え聞いてもいいね
スーパーかというと
スーパーハーフちょっと弱いよねあっ
場に何かもう数羽君は確かに挙げた佐手小で
んじゃぜん
car
uh
me
car
あっはぁ
中身があっ
スーパーカップでしたえっズンズン品のは高温のようなのか
うっ
はぁ
高級変わるのってくださいね